this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream watch
thousands of documentaries for free for
31 days a curiosity stream calm Ford /
real engineering this year at the f-35
is finally set to close its 27 year
development phase and move towards
high-volume manufacturing the
culmination of 27 years of design and
development from its manufacturer
Lockheed Martin 27 years of development
crossing the finish line in the midst of
a political power struggle in America
this is after all the most expensive
weapon system in the history of
humankind costs have inflated as a
result of the American
military-industrial complex where the
intertwining of politics economy and the
military industry encourages companies
like Lockheed Martin and Boeing to not
vertically integrate their companies as
a means of spreading jobs across America
and thereby increased political support
for these programs and the politicians
that approved them in Congress to win
contracts we could deep dive into these
muddied waters of politics but this
channel is about engineering and the
development costs of the f-35 would be
astronomical even without these issues
so let's explore the design of this
plane and see whether its price tag is
really worth it from the start the f-35
sought to be the jack-of-all-trades an
air superiority machine to replace the
air force's f-16s and a TENS a stealth
fighter taking the lessons learned from
the b-2 program and improving upon
Lockheed's previous ventures into
stealth technology with the f-22 Raptor
and the f-117 Nighthawk a carrier
capable fighter to replace the f-18
Hornets of the Navy and perhaps most
audacious of all it would take on the
challenge of vertical landings taking
over from the British av-8b Harrier
taking on all these advanced
technologies and combining them into one
plane was never going to be an easy or
cheap task and the program was made even
more expensive by what was initially
intended to be a cost-saving measure
this plane would be developed as a joint
venture between three US military
branches
the Air Force Navy and Marines a single
plane for each branch of the military
the program was named the Joint Strike
Fighter and its goal was to produce a
next-generation plane that could replace
fighter strike and ground attack
aircraft of not just the United States
but all of its allies
unlike the f-22 Raptor which is a US Air
Force exclusive plane
the f-35 would be commercially available
the Joint Strike Fighter program began
life as a competition between McDonnell
Douglas Northrop Gruman Lockheed Martin
and Boeing with Lockheed and Boeing
going on to develop prototype aircraft
as finalists in the competition both
eager to win what was sure to be one of
the most lucrative contracts they would
ever sign Boeing's aircraft the x32
was an odd-looking aircraft featuring a
massive single air intake that made it
less VTOL and more veal all its looks
alone may have stopped it from winning
this valuable contract but what really
held it back was Boeing's decision to
create two prototype planes one capable
of supersonic flight and one capable of
vertical takeoff using the same vector
thrust as the Harrier which it was
supposed to be replacing the engine used
in the Harrier is similar to a
traditional jet engine in that a
consists of a low pressure compressor
fan a high-pressure compressor a
combustion chamber a high-pressure
turbine and a low pressure turbine but
it's out less nozzle placement is
anything but traditional two outlets are
placed immediately after the
low-pressure compressor with another two
ducting air from the higher pressure
turbines in vertical thrust mode the
nozzles point downwards and allow the
plane to balance precariously on these
four columns of air the Harrier was not
an easy plane to control in this flight
mode and on more than one occasion
turbulence from its own downwash caused
the plane to flip over onto the cockpit
during landings killing the pilot a
large part of these control issues can
be attributed to the proximity of the
control nozzles to the center of gravity
of the plane giving them less mechanical
advantage to manipulate the plane's
attitude
the Harrier did have small roll control
nozzles on the tip of each wing but the
trol for these were entirely manual
placing the incredibly unstable control
mechanism into the hands of a human that
needed to focus on various other factors
when landing the x32 used many of the
same techniques to achieve vertical
thrust but improved on many of the
Harriers shortcomings instead of using
the same nozzles for cruise and direct
lift the x32
would close valves for each when needed
in normal flight the cruise nozzles
would open allowing the thrust of the
jet engine to be directed efficiently
through the rear of the aircraft then
during transition this nozzle would
close and force air through the direct
lift nozzles they placed a larger roll
control nozzles further from the planes
center of mass and also employed a cold
air screen placed just forward of the
lift nozzles this was intended to stop
hot turbulent air from the direct lift
nozzles from entering the front intake
which was a massive issue for the
harrier as it landed
jet engines need cold and smooth air to
operate at maximum thrust which was
difficult to get when landing and
directing the entirety of your thrust
directly at the ground despite these
improvements lockheed ultimately won the
contract impressing the Joint Strike
Fighter program with their left fan
system the engine thrust here once again
exits a single exhaust nozzle during
normal flight but when the show begins
the ex35 was capable of some incredible
Transformer like changes hatch is opened
on the top and bottom of the aircraft
revealing two contra rotating fans
another two little doors opened beneath
the wings exposing two additional
exhaust ports that controlled the
plane's roll finally as the plane begins
to slow down the crews nozzle would
begin to pivot downwards transitioning
the remaining thrust of the jet engine
from horizontal to vertical the lift fan
solved many of the same issues that
plagued the harrier the lift fan
produced the majority of the vertical
thrust and it did not heat up the air
significantly in the process the roll
control had significantly more
mechanical advantage and divvied the
majority of the control
over to a computer perhaps most
influential in their success to winning
the contract this prototype was capable
of both vertical landings and supersonic
flights this was the kind of innovation
the Joint Strike Fighter program was
looking for the lift fan is essentially
a turboprop engine like something you
would find on an osprey the propellers
are driven by a drive shaft connected to
the jet engine turbines which can be
disengaged during normal flies
this means the lift fan is dead waste
during cruise but what it adds and
weighs it more than makes up for in lift
combined these propulsion methods can
produce 185 kilonewtons of lift the
Harrier could only manage 106 this
increase in direct lift capabilities was
vital to making the f-35 a worthy
successor to the Harrier as one of the
Harriers greatest weaknesses was its
limitations in maximum takeoff and
landing weight the harrier like the
f-35b mostly operated in short takeoff
and vertical landing mode the Harrier
would point all four of its nozzles at
about a 45 degree angle allowing it to
produce both horizontal and vertical
thrust to take off from shorter runways
this allowed it to take off with
considerably more waste than it could
land with in a vertical landing the
empty weight of the f-35b
may be thirteen thousand one hundred and
fifty-four kilograms
compared to the six thousand three
hundred and forty kilograms of the
Harrier but it more than makes up for
that with a maximum takeoff weight of 31
thousand eight hundred kilograms
compared to the Harriers fourteen
thousand one hundred kilograms that's an
extra 11 tons of waste available to the
f-35 for fuel and a munitions something
the Harrier had little space for so the
f-35 is more than a worthy successor to
the Harrier a plane which fetched about
24 million dollars per unit in 1996 or
about 39 million adjusted for inflation
so incorporating VTOL to the f-35b was
just one of many design challenges that
pushed the price of the program off
ironically despite Boeing's joule
prototype entry being a sticking point
for the
sf Program the f-35 now comes in three
variants each tailored for different
branches in the US military
the f-35 a is customized for the US Air
Force and as such has been designed to
take off from conventional runways
allowing it to scrap much of the heavy
equipment needed for the f-35 be the
Marines variant the Marines do not
operate out of large aircraft carriers
like the Navy and as such their ships
like the wasp-class amphibious assault
ship have often been referred to as
helicopter carriers as no plane
other than the Harrier or Osprey have
been able to use them this is not the
case for the Navy who have large
aircraft carriers at their disposal the
final variant is the f-35 C which has
been designed to satisfy the Navy's
requirements having wings that are about
40% larger than either of its sister
variants and its landing gear is much
heavier and stronger both of these
features were included to allow it to
land and take off from aircraft carriers
without the need for the vertical
propulsion like the f-35b
the larger wings not only allow the
f-35c to have the largest fuel capacity
of the three but also give it much
better lift at slower speeds making
landings and takeoffs much easier on the
deck of an aircraft carrier while the
heavier landing gear allows the plane to
survive the rough landings associated
with the arresting wire landings on
aircraft carriers the f-35 see also
incorporates folding wingtips to allow
for neat storage inside the ship this
expansion into three variants has been a
huge source of increased costs and the
program likely could have dramatically
reduced on spending had it just designed
three different planes for three
different branches trying to squeeze the
needs of these three military branches
into a single airframe was never going
to be an easy task for the R&D division
of Lockheed Martin and forced them to
make some concessions in design that
have limited them in other areas the
brunt of criticism directed at the f-35
is its shortcomings in dog fighting
capabilities headlines of the f-35
losing simulated dogfights to cold
war-era f-15s and f-16s
grabbed many people's attention and were
used to detract from the f-35s
advancements we only knew about these
issues as a result of a report that
leaked to the press let's take a look at
that report to see what this test pilot
thought about the f-35 a he flew the
primary flaw of this pilot highlighted
was the f-35 A's poor energy
maneuverability meaning the f-35 a
struggled to maneuver without expending
a significant amount of its kinetic
energy which is a problem I discussed in
more detail in my fighter jet
instability video the primary design
aspect the pilot pins this on is the
smaller wing area and the weaker
afterburner thrust of the f-35 in
comparison to the f-15e he was
accustomed to essentially their issue
with the f-35 was that it depleted its
kinetic energy stored quicker than its
competition we have no reason to believe
this pilot was wrong in his findings so
what does this mean for the f-35 it is
important to note that this was not a
fully functional version missing
software enabling the plane to detect
its foes before they can detect it and
was missing radar absorbing paint on top
of this the f-35 is not short of trained
military aviators who praised the f-35
like US Marine corpse major dan Flatley
who helped design the combat training
program for f-35 pilots and he has
chopped up these issues to old habits of
pilots who have spent significant
portions of their lives dedicated to
older generation planes which were
designed with a different philosophy in
mind since then the f-35 has performed
phenomenally in simulations with the
reports up to 22 1 K TRS other pilots
who have had more time to become
accustomed to the f-35 had more positive
things to say like John Beasley the
chief test pilot of the f-35 with 22
years of experience as a test pilot at
Lockheed Martin and was involved in the
development of the f-117 Nighthawk and
the f-22 Raptor he claims the f-35 can
outmaneuver any US fighter except for
the f-22 which was designed specifically
as an air superiority machine and
is not available for purchase outside of
America and actually has a higher unit
cost than the f-35 at about a hundred
and fifty million dollars it's hard for
me to make a judgment call on this
because I have as little information as
any other civilian but honestly outside
of this one report most pilots who have
flown with the f-35 sing its praises
John Beasley also makes an important
note air combat has always relied on
stealth whether it was World War one
pilots diving from the Sun at their
backs or modern fighters using advanced
radar masks in design because in the
grand scheme of things in a dogfight the
real star that matters is who sees and
shoots first and the biggest factor that
contributes to that are the onboard
sensors and stealth the thing that
really sets the f-35 apart is its suite
of sensors and computer guidance systems
which have been integrated with the user
interface of the aircraft unlike any
other plane in the history of mankind
while sharing that information with the
entire force this is what truly makes
this plane something to be feared and it
all starts with this a little
transparent faceted sensor suite
containing the infrared imaging and
tracking equipment of the aircraft but
those are not your typical windows those
are made of sapphire and notoriously
expensive gemstone one of the few
materials that is both hard and durable
but also transparent to a broad range of
wavelets the imaging data from these
sensors can even be fed into the pilots
helmet visor which has been enhanced
with augmented reality technology this
helmet alone costs $400,000 and enables
the pilot to look straight through the
aircraft and see at night without having
to wear clumsy night-vision goggles the
helmet also feeds in data from the
multitude of other sensors like the
advanced high-frequency radar in the
nose of the plane along with data
received from sensors from other
aircraft and ground-based units the data
does not feed into the pilots AR helmet
unfiltered though it passes through the
on-board computer which performs all the
necessary filtering and data analysis
and only presents the pilot with the
information he really needs this
technology is so powerful that even an
unarmed f-35 would greatly boost the
combat effectiveness of its allies but
detection is just one step of that goal
of shooting first not being detected is
just as important incorporating stealth
was just another design challenge and is
likely the source of much of the
unexpected cost let's first clear
something up despite what you may have
otherwise heard stealth does not render
a plane undetectable short of not
physically existing everything is
detectable if we can find and analyze
planets billions of light-years away we
can detect a plane flying directly
overhead stealth purpose is not to make
the plane invisible it serves to
complicate and delay the enemy's
detection of an aircraft stealth has
proven itself invaluable over the past
two decades prior to the f-35s inception
the f-117 nighthawk flew over 1,300
missions over Iraq during the Gulf War
scouring direct hits on over 1600
high-value targets without losing a
single aircraft but it was far from
perfect
Lockheed knew this all too well as the
manufacturer of the f-117 in 1999 a
Nighthawk was infamously spotted by a
radar and subsequently shot down over
Serbia the pilot survived but the plane
crashed and remained mostly intact
handing over a valuable technology to
the Russians to reverse-engineer Celt
serves a single purpose to avoid
detection and the f-117 failed here but
it was developed using 1970s era
computing technology it's panels were
flat and faceted simply because we did
not have the computers capable of
analyzing more complicated shapes to
optimize stealth early attempts at
stealth worked under a fairly simple
theory radar works by sending out pulses
of electromagnetic waves and waits and
listens for reflections the idea behind
stealth technology is to not reflect
those waves back at the emitter and thus
avoiding detection this is why the f-117
is shaped like this each panel has been
angled and placed in a way to minimize
how much of this energy it will reflect
back to the sender it was also coated in
a paint that would help absorb some of
that electromagnetic radiation a
opponents of stealth technology despite
its proven track record are quick to
point out that long wavelength radar is
capable of detecting stealth aircraft
the same kind of radar that detected the
f-117 over Serbia and the same kind of
radar used in the Battle of Britain
while this is true these stealth
aircraft are optimized to avoid
detection of higher frequency radar
those opponents rarely mentioned that
low frequency long wavelength radar do
not provide high fidelity measurements
and struggle to pinpoint their location
of the aircraft this makes them
effective early warning systems but
entirely useless for directing missiles
while this is certainly not useless it's
not particularly useful in air-to-air
combat had the f-117 nighthawk on that
night been escorted by its usual
squadron of electronic jamming Prowler
aircraft the missiles may well have
never got a lock this was made worse by
the fact the aircraft was flying a
regular flight path and so the Serbians
knew where to look
topping this off the f-117 was designed
in an era before sophisticated
computational analysis was available and
so it took this relatively simplistic
flat faceted form the b2 and f-22
however greatly improved on the
technology utilizing complex curved
shapes which no human could hope to
calculate the radar signature of and
they have never been shut down the
curves diffused those radio waves in
many directions rather than reflecting
it all in one direction which makes it
easier to detect by receivers listening
in locations separate to the emitter a
fairly standard practice today
the f-35 uses the same complex curves to
avoid detection by these high-frequency
radars and this is likely one of the
things driving its development costs up
the most stealth technology requires
precision beyond any other type of
manufacturing this is manageable at
small-scale production like that of the
b2 and f-22 which had very small
production runs the f-35 however is
expected to be a mass manufactured
aircraft that foreign allies with
shallower pockets than the US military
will be willing to pay for creating a
manufacturing line that requires this
level of precision was never going to be
panels cannot have gaps between them
that cannot be malformed a single
scratch on the radar-absorbing coating
will require an entire repaint of the
parrot small manufacturing defects have
caused recalls on multiple occasions
Lockheed is only now starting to
comfortably roll the plane off the
assembly lines and that is reflected in
the lowering price of the aircraft the
latest batch of orders have reduced and
cost by 5.4 percent for the f-35 a 5.7
for the B variant an 11.1% for the f-35
see leaving us with a unit cost of 89
point two million for an f-35 a a
hundred and fifteen point five million
for an f-35 B and one hundred and seven
point seven million for an f-35 see with
the f-35 a expected to drop by a further
four point seven percent to 85 million
by the end of 2019 this sounds like a
shitload of money to the average person
like me but we get a clearer picture of
these costs when comparing to other
fifth-generation fighters like the f-22
Raptor which cost a hundred and fifty
million dollars per unit or even looking
at the other aircraft it's going to be
replacing I think it's fair to say that
we've established that the f-35 is a
worthy successor to all of these planes
which individually come with their own
hefty price tags but the f-35 manages to
combine the capabilities of all these
aircraft into a single plane yes the
development cost of this plane have been
astronomical that cannot be denied but
much of that money has gone directly
back into the American economy then when
you consider that the plane is expected
to sell up to 4600 units by the end of
its lifetime nearly identical to the
total f-16 sales figures this will
inject more money into the American
economy considering a large sum of these
orders will be from international
exports so is the f-35 worth it's 115
point five million price tag as an Irish
citizen that's not for me to decide but
I can't say one thing this is a
fascinating plane with astounding
capabilities this may have been a heavy
price to pay
but what isn't is a subscription to
curiosity stream at a price of just
$2.99 a month with that price you will
get access to thousands of documentaries
and nonfiction titles like this
fantastic history of weapons series not
only that you will also get free access
to nebula the streaming video platform
built by and for independent creators
like tear Zoo Lindsay Alice
minutephysics Wendover productions and
my new channel real science which just
launched last week where curiosity
stream is all about big-budget
non-fiction videos we're building nebula
because we want a place for educational
creators to try out new content ideas
that might not work on YouTube I'm
currently working on a logistics of
d-day series and the next episode of
real science is already available on
there but won't be on YouTube for
another month curiosity stream loves
independent creators and wants to help
us grow our platform so they're offering
real engineering viewers free access to
nebula when you sign up to curiosity
stream comm Ford slash real engineering
by signing up to curiosity stream you
will be helping not just me but the
entire educational community as we work
together to build a place where we can
create content like my logistics of
d-day series that would just be too
risky to rely on YouTube as always
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below
you
[Music]